MAYBE HE RESPONDED THE RIGHT WAY
BEFORE HE WENT BEFORE THE SENATE
AND SHOWED RIGHTEOUS ANGER AND
INDIGNATION AFTER BEING ACCUSED
OF BEING A GANG.
BEFORE I WOULD BE SURPRISED IF
SUSAN COLLINS DID THAT.
I THINK SHE IS A SERIOUS PERSON
AND REALLY SET A STANDARD AND
SAID, LET'S GET AN INVESTIGATIO
INVESTIGATION.
APPARENTLY THE FBI CAME BACK AND
SAID, THERE IS NOTHING THERE.
>> Sean: BUT THEY REITERATED
THE SENATE JUDICIARY
INVESTIGATION.
>> Newt: YES.
SO MY GUESS IS YOU HAVE
SENATOR COLLINS AND
SENATOR MURKOWSKI WHICH ARE
SOLID PEOPLE THAT HAVE TALK THIS
THROUGH, AND I THINK THEY WILL
TALK THIS THROUGH FOR THE JUDGE.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT FLAKE WILL DO
ALTHOUGH HE INDICATED PRETTY
CLEARLY IF THE FBI COMES UP WITH
NOTHING, HE WILL VOTE YES.
I THINK THE ODDS ARE PRETTY HIGH
THAT JOE MANCHIN, THE SENATOR
FROM WEST VIRGINIA IS GOING TO
VOTE YES.
YOU WILL BE IN A STATE WHERE
TRUMP GOT 46% MARGIN, IT'S A
CERTAIN LEVEL OF, IF YOU ARE UP
FOR REELECTION, PRESUMPTION.
SO TONIGHT MAYBE THINGS WILL
CHANGE BUT MY SENSES TONIGHT
THAT YOU ARE GOING TO HAVE
EITHER SATURDAY OR MONDAY, A
"YES" VOTE, AND HE WILL BE
CONFIRMED.
THE ONE I HOPE YOU ARE RIGHT.
34 DAYS FROM NOW.
I KNEW YOU BACK IN '94.
I KNEW YOU THE DAY OF THE
ELECTION AND THE DAY BEFORE.
THAT'S A NIGHT YOU BECAME
SPEAKER OF THE HOUSE.
RENEWING CIVILIZATION,
CULMINATING A CONTRACT WITH
AMERICA AND CULMINATING THE
REPUBLICANS COMING TO POWER FOR
THE FIRST TIME IN 40 YEARS.
CONFIDENT, WE ARE GOING TO WIN.
THAT'S A PRETTY BOLD PREDICTION
CONSIDERING REPUBLICANS HADN'T
WON IN 40 YEARS, BUT WERE RIGHT.
YOU HAVE A DEGREE OF OPTIMISM
ABOUT THE ELECTION IN 34 DAYS
MAY BE BECAUSE I'M IRISH, OR
MAYBE BECAUSE I'VE ALWAYS
EXPECTED THE WORST THE NEXT
SECOND OF ANY DAY BUT I DON'T
HAVE THE CONFIDENCE YOU DO.
>> I THINK I'M A LOT LIKE REAGAN
IN THAT I REALLY BELIEVE IN THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I BELIEVE THE AVERAGE AMERICAN
SAW ALL OF THIS CHARACTER
ASSASSINATION, SMEARING,
DISHONESTY AND MANIPULATION.
I THINK THEY LOOK AT A
REPUBLICAN TEAM LED BY TRUMP
THAT IS A REALLY DELIVERING AND
GETTING THINGS DONE, AND SO
THEN, THEY LOOK OVER HERE AT THE
IS DEMOCRATS WHO HAVE REALLY
BEEN TRYING TO BLOCK EVERYTHING,
AND THEY HAVE IT RESULTS OVER
HERE, REAL RESULTS.
JOBS, BREAKTHROUGHS ON TRADE,
THINGS THAT ARE HAPPENING THAT
ARE TREMENDOUS.
YOU LOOK OVER HERE AT THESE
PEOPLE WHO SEEM TO FIGHT
EVERYTHING.
I SAID, THIS IS WHAT HAPPENED TO
ME IN 2016, BECAUSE I REMEMBER
DOING A SHOW WITH MEGYN KELLY
TWO WEEKS OUT.
AND I FINALLY SAID, -- AND IT'S
IN THE TAPE.
I DON'T THINK AMERICAN PEOPLE
ARE GOING TO LIKE SOMEBODY AS
CORRUPT AS HILLARY CLINTON.
I JUST DIDN'T BELIEVE IT ABOUT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
I DO NOT BELIEVE TONIGHT THAT
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE ARE GOING TO
REWARD LEFT-WING SOCIALISTS,
PEOPLE WHO WANT TO OBSTRUCT
EVERYTHING, BY GIVING THEM
POWER.
SO I AM MODERATELY OPTIMISTIC.
I WOULDN'T BET THE FAMILY FARM
BUT I WOULD BET A HORSE OR TWO.
>> Sean: I DIDN'T EVEN KNOW
YOU HAD HORSES BUT, GLAD TO HEAR
IT.
IT COMES DOWN TO INDIVIDUAL
DISTRICTS.
AND THERE ARE A LOT OF NEW
PEOPLE, LOTS OF RETIREMENTS THIS
YEAR.
THAT RAISES AN UNKNOWN QUESTION.
I DO THINK JOE MANCHIN IS IN
TROUBLE, I THINK NELSON IS IN
TROUBLE, DONNELLY IS IN TROUBLE,
HESTER AND MONTANA -- SOME OF
THESE RACES ARE VERY CLOSE
BUT -- >> Newt: I THINK THE
SENATE, WE ARE VERY -- AND BY
THE WAY IN MINNESOTA, YOU HAVE A
VERY REAL POSSIBILITY OF AN
UPSET BECAUSE I THINK THE
REPUBLICAN NOMINEE IS A VERY
ATTRACTIVE WOMAN AND THE OTHER
NOMINEE HAS TO CARRY THE SOUL
WRATH OF KEITH ELLISON.
HOW DOES SHE CAMPAIGN A TICKET
WHEN TWO DIFFERENT WOMEN SAY
THAT HE HAD TO USE THEM?
>> Sean: WHY DIDN'T THEY ASK
FOR AN FBI INVESTIGATION INTO
HIM?
OR IF WE ARE GOING BACK TO
KAVANAUGH'S TEENAGE SHEET YEARS
THEN WE COULD AT LEAST GO BACK
TO THE TIME WHERE BILL CLINTON
WAS THE ARKANSAS
ATTORNEY GENERAL, WASN'T HE?
>> I JUST THINK THE PRESIDENT
WILL BE IN MINNESOTA TOMORROW
AND HE WILL HAVE A CHANCE TO --
>> THESE ARE STATES THAT YOU
WOULDN'T THINK, WHERE THE HOUSES
AND PLAY.
>> AND A NUMBER OF THESE PLACES
HE WILL BE ABLE TO GO IN AND
CAMPAIGN FOR THE HOUSE NUMBER
AND YOU CAN SEE THE SWEET
BUILDING.
BE ONE WHERE THE HISTORIAN, IT'S
ONLY HAPPENED THREE TIMES IN 100
YEARS.
THE PARTY WINS THE WHITE HOUSE
AND DOESN'T LOSE SEATS IN THE
FIRST MIDTERM.
>> I DON'T WANT TO SOUND SILLY
ABOUT THIS BUT, ALL I CAN TELL
YOU IS, YOU ARE IN A DIFFERENT
WORLD RIGHT NOW.
YOU GOT SOMEBODY WHO IS A GREAT
NATURAL CAMPAIGNER AND DRAWS
HUGE CROWDS.
>> Sean: ALL THESE SUPPORTERS
UNDERSTAND THAT WHAT THEY VOTED
FOR IN 2016 THAT THEY HAVE TRIED
TO TEAR DOWN ALMOST FROM DAY
ONE, AND DESTROY HIM, DO YOU
THINK THAT THEY KNOW THAT THAT
IS ALL IN JEOPARDY?
>> Newt: I THINK THE LIBERALS
ASSAULT ON KAVANAUGH HAS AROUSED
CONSERVATIVES AND MODERATES,
DECENT PEOPLE, PEOPLE WHO
BELIEVE IN THE RULE OF LAW AND
PEOPLE WHO BELIEVE IN FAIRNESS.
I WAS IN PHOENIX YESTERDAY WITH
ABOUT 850 PEOPLE AT A
RADIO STATION.
THE ONE THAT'S NOT QUITE THE
SIZE OF A TRUMP RALLY.
I'M JUST TEASING.
>> Newt: AND NEITHER HE NOR I
GET 6 MILLION PEOPLE IN THE
EVENING.
WE DON'T QUITE GET A HANNITY
BROADCAST BUT THE POINT IS, THE
PEOPLE I SAW WERE ON FIRE.
AND THEY WANT TO MAKE SURE
THAT -- >> Sean: SHE'S A GREAT
CANDIDATE.
SALLY, HELLER, THOSE ARE ALL
RACES AND IT'S CLOSE.
EVERY VOTE IS GOING TO MATTER.
>> Newt: I'M GOING TO BE AN